i'm joined by charlotte robson who is a
board member of the newcastle united
supporters trust she's normally on
tyneside we find her in london today
what a time to be away from your home
city big news could be coming this
afternoon
the absolute worst time ever i'm here
for a wedding at the weekend and on the
train last night as all this news
started breaking i was just like
oh this is this is a bad time to leave
this is a terrible time to leave time
side yeah but what a party you may have
this weekend if it's confirmed this
afternoon as expected that this saudi
arabian consortium are going to take
over your club newcastle is on the verge
of having its chelsea roman abramovich
moment if you like charlotte but it's
bigger than that isn't it because it
won't just make you the richest club in
the premier league it'll make you the
richest club in the world
yeah by some margin yeah um
it's unfathomable and i can't speak um
we have um
we have had 14 years of of an owner who
you know
hasn't been as in put as much investment
into the club by any stretch
um
that the fans would like and so to have
an owner with
such cheap pockets is really exciting
we're not looking i don't think as a fan
base we're looking for immediately
buying out pep guardiola and bringing
him on to tyneside although
you know let's do that um
i think as a fan base we're just really
excited to have new owners that are
ambitious and are going to have a plan
and are going to invest in in the region
as well in the community yeah you
mentioned mike ashley there before we
move on to the prospective new owners
let's talk about mike ashley 14 years at
the helm of newcastle united when he
arrived at st james's park he said he
was looking for fun
and trophies turns out you got neither
newcastle united fans
have not been very happy with him to to
put it mildly over the last 14 years
charlotte can you up some what the
ashley era has been like for you
um for me yes the ashley era has been
devoid of hope
um it has been tergen football
it has been um to quote steve bruce our
current head coach ticking along you
know that the mike ashley era to me as a
fan
has been about remaining in the premier
league but doing so
at sort of at baseline cost we have been
relegated twice since mike ashley has
run the club um we've come back uh each
time because of uh
investment he's put in but immediately
then taken out
um we don't
buy any uh
exciting players or we do so very
infrequently um and and it's about
sticking plasters over quite significant
wounds for me uh that's what that's what
his tenure has been like
so newcastle united fans want change
they don't want mike ashley
are they happy with having saudi arabia
instead of mike ashley because you know
the question i'm going to ask charlotte
this is going to be a controversial deal
if it does go through human rights
groups have already pointed out and you
know people are well aware of saudi
arabia's
human rights record
it is not good a newcastle united fans
happy to be associated with that or will
they just as my colleague jane zecker
put it earlier on to another fans group
just hold their nose and get on with it
i think it's a really big question and i
can't answer on behalf of every
newcastle united fan um if they're happy
to be owned by
the public investment fund of saudi
arabia should that come to fruition
today
i think um
i think the happiness on tyneside right
now is that mike ashley is gone or
we cross our fingers that that is the
case
um
i i i think it's really difficult i
think
i think that ambition has returned to
the club and and
if you look at twitter newcastle united
twitter has been so divided over the
last year and a half two years
to see it just united in excitement
about what the future might hold i i
think that's what that's what fans are
focusing on right now
and charlotte i will point out as many
people on social media have asked me to
this afternoon that saudi arabia is
involved
in other sports uh it's hosted boxing
there was similar questions asked then
it hosts a formula one race similar
questions were asked then it's involved
in horse racing a hugely popular sport
in this country a lot of people saying
why is it always put on the shoulders of
sports fans to make these ethical
choices isn't it up to governments who
do business deals with saudi arabia who
sell arms to saudi arabia so sports fans
are getting quite angry
that they're always being asked to make
these ethical choices
yeah
look i i
i think that it does it shouldn't fall
to fans sort of like dave in newcastle
suddenly being asked to be
the voice on
a nation states human rights record like
i just don't think that's fair i think
if you were gonna if you were gonna
criticize anyone for this acquisition
should it happen
you have to you have to look at the
premier league you have to look at the
government you have to look at how
we interact with saudi arabia as a as a
country i just think putting it on fans
is deeply unfair
when people are just
doing their jobs going about their
normal life and want to enjoy their
football on the weekend i i know that
seems simplistic
but that is what it boils down to it's a
really good learning opportunity
and it's a really good conversation to
open up we should we should be having it
but come you're right putting it down on
the fans is just not fair yeah charlotte
you raise a good point there about the
premier league and their vetting process
and it's been criticized for many years
for various different takeovers and it
seems that this consortium has now
passed all the business uh tests uh or
the viable uh financial tests but there
are no moral or ethical tests involved
in the setup uh for the premier league
to approve takeovers of club do you
think that that is something that should
be put in as part and parcel of this
testing process for anyone wanting to
own a football club
it's a difficult one because they do
have they did have this sort of
wanting to uh establish separation so
it's the public investment fund of saudi
arabia that has allegedly bought new
castle united
and
there was the question last year because
this was muted last year there was a
question last year of whether or not
that meant that the kingdom of saudi
arabia which runs the investment fund or
or there is a
blurred line there are they actually
going to be the ones that are running
newcastle united now i i understand that
that issue of separation has now been
settled because that was the key part of
arbitration that newcastle united was
going to go to in january
if that's the case then then there is a
bit of a moral sort of ethical question
um being asked and being answered um
but i i kind of i kind of sort of
bristle a little bit at the idea that it
should be
up to a sport sort of to to to be the
moral and ethical arbiters of of
buyers i don't know i don't know the
answer to it no no it's a it's a
complicated issue and like you said when
it comes to you know qatar hosting the
world cup for example or you know
as we said boxing being held in saudi
arabia these conversations keep coming
up but somehow it continues and just
gets brushed under the carpet it's just
reared its head again so it was
interesting to get your point of view
charlotte um let's end on an upbeat note
if this takeover goes through today it's
not just transformative for your club
yeah fingers crossed it's not just just
transformative for your club but it's
transformative for the city as well
because for those who are watching who
aren't football fans but may well have
been to newcastle so jason's park is
right at the heart
of newcastle if you're shopping in
newcastle on a saturday afternoon a gold
coasin you can hear the cheers from the
shops it's very much
newcastle so how transformative is it
going to be for the city as well as the
club charlotte
literally giving me goosebumps saying
that by the way
um i it's huge it's it's massive and
as you mentioned at the start of this
interview
the the pockets of this these people are
very deep
and so
and they've also already made the right
noises about investment in community
investment in the academy investment in
the ground the the stadium needs
upgrades it needs a new roof it needs
paint it needs you know all kinds of
things and and so
and so for that sort of investment to
start happening i just think the region
is going to benefit i think
you look at the geographical um
potential of fans coming to newcastle
united and to newcastle
there isn't another club another premier
league club until going south until you
get to leeds there's nothing going west
there's scotland north
there's nothing else so there's so much
potential for the region to really sort
of benefit from this and that really
excites me because
newcastle united is rooted in its
community and i'm very proud to be part
of that community and
i just
the potential now is huge that certainly
is um charlotte let's hope it's a double
celebration for you at this wedding this
weekend are the bride and groom
newcastle united fans by any chance
no they're not they're londoners
unfortunately oh
well hopefully
hopefully they'll be pleased enough for
you for you to wear your newcastle
united shirt to the wedding should this
take over deal go through today uh
charlotte thank you so much charlotte
robson uh from the newcastle united
supporters trust ahead of that proposed
takeover by a saudi arabia consortium we
hear it's going to go through before the
end of the day